[Music]
okay everyone I'm so excited today
because I am joined by Riley Keough and
Sam Claflin who star in Daisy Jones and
the six on Prime video which is out
tomorrow how you guys doing today
we're doing good this is our very first
interview together oh that's exciting
I'm honored to be doing it that's that's
awesome so uh Riley when you're playing
a beloved character from a beloved book
how do you decide like where you're
going to lean into most of the portrayal
of Daisy meaning like the books version
versus script version versus what you
have in your mind
um that's a good question you know I I
think the combination of the book and
the script she was very um well written
so I had a lot of material to draw from
and then in terms of
um you know the way she looked in her
costume and hair and everything I
actually like
found a lot of inspiration through fan
art on the internet so when I was sort
of yeah yeah so I when I was when we
were talking about what her hair should
look like and if she should have bangs
or what color the hair should be
um I like looked on Instagram at Daisy
Jones fan art and then you know kind of
found the color and the like bangs
through that oh my God that's that's
just gold that you're giving me Golds
Sam
um does acting as someone singing make
it less terrifying to sing or is it
always scary just to sing like getting
in characters are you not scared of it
at all he wants to sing right now I've
heard something oh yeah
I've never sung without being in
character I've only ever done musical
theater
um so priest number four was my
introduction into into musical combat
um but no I I honestly I remember like
during this process they were like Okay
um Sam you're starting to sound like
Blake that they'd re recorded all the
songs with Blake who'd written most of
the songs right Sam you're starting to
sound like Blake I was like isn't that
what you want me to sound like isn't
that you know and I was all they were
like no what's your voice I was like I
don't know I don't know what my voice is
I've never really sung properly uh so
then they found like someone else
um who who they I was like just find
someone you want me to sound like and
I'll I'll just do my impression of them
and that's basically what you hear on
what you hear on the records is me doing
my best impression of James yeah oh
that's amazing yeah it's it's great you
just kill it
um now speaking of singing Riley we see
in the show that Daisy sometimes before
she sings has this whiskey milk combo
have you ever done that yourself before
singing or do you have a different
approach
um funny story
it's actually not that funny but I think
one of the first times I was in Sound
City and I'm not a very big drinker
um
have you ever seen any drinks no
um and um Tony Berg who is one of the
producers of the music
um I don't know he just like came up to
me with a shot of whiskey and it was
like 10 in the morning and I and I was
like oh my God I can't take a shot at 10
in the morning that's outrageous so I
just like I just politely sort of like
sipped it
um but yeah so I tried that once oh and
actually before my audition did you have
the Moonshine what what
Frankie Frankie forced me to have
moonshine before my audition that is
hard you know this is so rock and roll I
didn't know this was a real drink that
is like very Southern hey well you know
um yeah I've had I've had whiskey before
singing twice but like a tiny little sip
oh no I love that yeah so this isn't new
to you great and you you absolutely just
kill it as Daisy so everybody watch
Riley and Sam crush it in Daisy Jones
and the six on Prime video tomorrow
thank you guys so much for joining me
and I will talk to you in the future one
day bye cheers thank you